logan if someone new to screenwriting
and filmmaking said to you
how do i get my script to and then fill
in the blank of some
famous director from you know ryan
coogler ryan johnson zack snyder etc it
could be so many names what would your
advice be what would you say to them
my advice would be
that
it's twofold
i i cannot speak for any specific
individual
the
the sort of walls around making that
happen
are very very tall and
hard to climb and i
and again
999 times out of a thousand
it's not going to go
anywhere probably
i do think
that having the sort of attitude of
being willing to like to cold call and
do outreach to people
and
and to take on that responsibility
yourself i think is a really positive
um
that's a really positive character trait
uh with the caveat of that i do think
that sometimes now
um
people
people aren't being as
i've seen a lot of examples of people
not being as
professional or responsible about that
as i think that they should be
um
i mean again it sort of makes common
sense if you're trying to do outreach to
people to give you an opportunity
like you should
you probably want to do that with your
best foot forward for all sorts of
reasons right um
but so i do think that that's the sort
of like line to walk which is you
you have to know going into any sort of
situation it's probably not going to
happen but you
you should also have the attitude to
sort of like keep trying and try to come
up with the best way
forward
um
and i don't and again and i don't mean
anything crazy i just mean that
it's a positive
it's a positive character trait to go
like i'm going to take on
the responsibility of myself of trying
to make things happen
for myself
and unders like because to me it's the
sort of thing where it's like even once
you have a larger team and more like
relationships and stuff it's still like
a lot of it still falls upon you
to do the legwork right
and
and so you should be comfortable with
that and you should be somebody like and
if you're not somebody who is super
comfortable with that i would figure out
ways to become more comfortable with
that
um honestly
don't harass people also
oh sure sure absolutely but i'm
wondering if there's another turn and
that would be
what about the advice of if this is your
first script
don't bother like make it yourself like
you're not
as cold as i said maybe this you're not
ready yet to reach out to
the nolans of the world
however great you think it might be kind
of thing but like go and have it
produced yourself you know find someone
and if you can't try crowdfunding
and and and if not
try other avenues i don't want to
recommend credit cards because i don't
think that's a good idea i know people
do it but
instead of like no
you know
jerry bruckheimer has to get this
i have to find him to get you know what
i'm saying and so yeah and there's a lot
of mentality out there like that and um
especially probably people in other
states
um hollywood i think once you get here
you start to realize okay that's
probably not a good idea but
it sounds good in theory if if only
so-and-so saw this it would be a done
deal
yeah i think that
my sort of perspective on that would be
that
to again to be
to be flexible
and
and to be aware of like what the goals
are
and how you're like
what are you trying like ultimately like
what are you trying to do what is the
point of this like project to you right
is it does it exist solely to get
representation does it exist to like to
pitch a like is it a short exist to
pitch a feature to sell that
like
whatever those goals are
and then knowing that
there's a lot of different ways to
approach
that sort of situation
that probably takes a lot of outside of
the box thinking i would say that
outside of literally like
again i don't want to hurt anyone's
feelings like jerry bruckheimer doesn't
want to like
doesn't want to talk to you he doesn't
want to talk to i mean
he has his friends and his family he's
busy
um
but
but i think that like to me what's
important is
how do you make the situation
like work for you like how oh no this is
what i was gonna say i'm sorry i was
going to say that even if that was a
viable like path
right
that is also the path that
the reason that these sort of like um
you know
whoever the celebrities or whatever why
they put up these walls is because
they're being inundated with people all
day long
right that's why they have all these
defenses because
because it's a very obvious path that
everybody's like all trying to crowd
into
right
and so
the other thought that i would have is
what is a not obvious path
why would i
why would i approach something
where the odds were already so
ridiculously stacked against me just
because it's so crowded why would this
is actually a thing that like
for for la people right or i'm sure
there's equivalent like uh in la there's
a couple like huge major thoroughfares
right that are not like the high like
not the freeways um
it's like going across town it's like uh
beverly and melrose and santa monica
right i'm
at rush hour or at any time i never go
down beverly or melrose or santa monica
or third i will never
because i'm gonna be stuck in
bumper-to-bumper traffic there's a
zillion
it's a metropolis there's a zillion
other streets that are all going the
same direction and you'll still end up
like
where you want to go if i'm just trying
to go to some place on the east side
what matters is that i get to my
destination it doesn't matter
how i got there
and i would
i would really suggest to people to
really think outside the box and be
imaginative about like again like what
is the goal
and
how do i create like
how do i get there that's again
utilizing sort of like out of the box
like thinking you know
because i
uh
anything that i've accomplished had
nothing to do with
like name brand like uh celebrities
like
and again i'm
i'm not
the like end-all be-all most successful
person of all time
but i
but i wouldn't have even
gone down that path anyway because i
it just feels like it's not like it
feels like there's so many alternatives
that feel a lot more viable